[Music]
i don't know how i think of some of my
ideas to be honest
yeah i don't know i just really like
crafting
[Music]
on tiktok and instagram i'm known as
home daddy way that this
all started with two years ago my
partner and i relocated to california
from new york for his job we had both
spent our entire lives in new york but
it was an opportunity for him that we
couldn't pass up but we did it but then
we got here and
i kind of fell into
a depression i didn't have my job
anymore i didn't have my family i didn't
have my friends and i started to just
wallow in those sad feelings i couldn't
get out of my home
and one day i was sitting out on my
balcony i didn't have any flowers i
didn't have any hummingbird feeders it
was just me sitting out there when a
hummingbird appeared out of nowhere
right in front of my face we locked eyes
with each other and then the hummingbird
flew away but when it flew away it took
with it all of that weight that i was
carrying i just felt lifted in that
moment it was the first time i felt good
in a long time
so it became this meditative thing for
me that just brought me so much peace it
helped ground me it helped put
everything in perspective
i started out simply with just basic
hand feeding
i wanted to like try to feed them
by my mouth or through my nose or
through my ears and i started to do all
those crazy things and then i kind of
ran out of uh real estate on my body to
feed them with and i had to introduce
props
i have like all these crazy different
props and here's a wig that i turned
into a feeder
i was not telling my friends and family
about it i'm like because the moment i
tell them it's gonna like fizzle out and
i'm gonna be yesterday's news so
only recently did people start to reach
out to me and say james
do you have something to tell us like
i'm seeing these videos of you
my mom went to get her hair cut
and her hairdresser said my daughter
follows your son on tick tock and my mom
was like what are you talking about so
all of my family have these little
stories of like the first time they've
heard about this alter ego hum daddy
that i have
if this inspires anyone to want to do
this and feed hummingbirds there is just
a certain level of responsibility that
comes with it feed them the right things
and clean your feeders do it responsibly
have a great time
you